I mean everything is very much I if it's
not on pause then it's on slow down mode
so um you know the the schools are
working um but they're not up to full
speed I get my son's High School more
than half of the teachers are in
reserves so they have and and that's the
case in most of the schools where you
just have a lot of teachers that have
been called up for reserves or the
husbands of the teachers uh at the
elementary school where most the
teachers are women so I mean you just
the entire the entire country is
mobilized and everybody goes to funerals
because everybody I mean particularly
where we live there are a lot of
soldiers who have been killed from our
community and from neighboring
communities and so we seem to go to
funerals all the time so there's a it's
a just it's a very we're on war footing
as a
country I'm Dave Ruben and joining me
today is the host of the Caroline Glick
show as well as senior contributing
editor at the Jewish news Syndicate
Caroline Glick welcome to the Ruben
report finally I should say finally
thanks for having me on your program
glad to be here delighted actually thank
you for having me well I wish that you
were on under better circumstances
you're in Israel right now obviously I
want to hear the latest and hear how how
you are doing and and all that stuff but
I do want to mention that when I was in
Israel about eight months or so ago uh I
was on your show uh it is very obvious
to me you are one of the clearest
thinkers in terms of the politics of
Israel and and really the geopolitics of
the whole area so that's really why I
wanted to sit down with you now um I
guess first off how are you how what is
the state of the country right now the
the feeling of the people before we get
into the sheer political nature of
everything well you know we're we're
doing we're doing fine uh our son is in
h Gaza um and uh so that's a little bit
uh
uh I mean it's very it causes a lot of
anxiety but um you know the the entire
country is basically right now hostage
in Gaza I just spoke this morning uh to
the father of one of the hostages there
and he made the point uh that um you
know we have seven million Jews who have
been Hostage to Hamas for many many
years they can shoot missiles at us
whenever they want and we get to decide
who sleeps in their bed and who sleeps
in bomb shelters whenever they want we
have on average two th000 missiles have
been shot from Gaza into Israel by Hamas
and Islamic Jihad and fatak and the rest
of them uh over the past over decade so
this is this is something that just has
to end and you have a great sense of
determination in Israel the likes of
which really I haven't seen I don't
think I've seen before although I've
seen us in very very determined moods U
like during the height of the terrorism
at the beginning of the century from 20
to 2004 and particularly in 2002 which
was the worst year of the Palestinian
Terror Onslaught then so I've seen us
very very determined in the past but the
mood here is is still different uh
people understand that this is a war for
our very existence that if we don't
eradicate Kamas and
significantly uh bring down kis bala's
ability to uh to attack us from the
north um then we are we are going to be
our actual existence is going to be
brought into question because um
Everybody expects us to do this we have
to do it we can't live securely with
these jihadist uh Terror groups on our
borders and so the determination really
is I think the main thing that people
feel even more than the anxiety which is
also extremely strong yeah can you just
talk a little bit about just what what
day-today life I mean I think it's hard
for Americans I obviously have an
international audience but I think it's
hard for people in virtually any other
country on Earth to to imagine what it
would be like I mean not only the
hostage situation where it's such a
small country that everyone knows
somebody who knows somebody who is
either killed or hostage but the
onslaught of rockets keeps coming you
you still have to have an economy you
still have to send kids to school etc
etc can you just talk about that a
little
bit um I mean everything is very much I
if it's not on pause then it's on
slowdown mode so um you know the the
schools are working um but they're not
up to full speed I get my son's High
School more than half of the teachers
are in reserves so they have and and
that's the case in most of the schools
where you just have a lot of teachers
that have been called up for reserves or
the husbands of the teachers uh at the
elementary school where most of the
teachers are women so I mean you just
the entire the entire country is
mobilized and everybody goes to funerals
because everybody I mean particularly
where we live there are a lot of
soldiers who have been killed from our
community and from neighboring
communities and so we seem to go to
funerals all the time so there's a it's
a just it's a very we're on war footing
as a country everybody's on heightened
alert uh a lot more guards everywhere um
in our community the entrances have been
sandbagged uh and uh and uh so you know
you just and like my husband and I we
haven't put away our Firearms since
October 7th we we carry them everywhere
we go so I mean it it's just the country
is mobilized I think if you were trying
to liken it to something that people can
imagine then it would be more like uh
London under the blitz that there's just
a sense all the time that the war kind
of permeates Everything All the Small
Talk um the life you go into a mall and
and you feel it I mean you feel it
everywhere can you talk about the
tension between Israel having to go into
Gaza to eliminate Hamas and then also
having to try to keep the I think it's
around 122 hostages that they believe
are alive right now keep them alive and
and actually get them out that those
those goals in some ways are in conflict
with each other which is making this
obviously really
complex well it's very complicated uh
you're right because they do seem to be
in conflict and and you also I mean I
guess it's regrettable maybe we
shouldn't be surprised by it but it's
it's sort of vicious that you know how
when you were here we were sort of in
the middle of uh a massive amount of
political Strife where the left had
rejected the outcome in the elections in
November of 2022 and they were having
these massive demonstrations all over
the country all the time and so the
people who were organizing these
demonstrations are sort of this click
around a former prime minister named a
Barack and they have not allowed this
war to really stop them so one of the
things that they did was they
capitalized on the hostage uh crisis and
took over the pr campaign for for the
hostages family really like on October 8
and they tried to politicize the entire
issue to make it about netan and use it
as a pivot to call for uh his
resignation and it's very ugly it's a
and and um so now you're seeing splits
inside of the families of the hostages
between a few of the families who are
going with these political activists and
uh many more who are not and it's and
it's sort of it it's a it's a source of
strife and it's being pumped up by our
media here which is also very um very
politicized so that's kind of the ugly
part of what we have here but I think
that I mean like the the hostage the
atan Moore I spoke with his father this
morning on my show the the program will
be going up later today and you know the
father father said look it's very clear
to us that um the only way to securely
get our hostages out is to win and we
can't lower the tempo on the operation
and he may be sort of an extreme voice
in the sense that he doesn't you know he
he told me that he and his son had had a
conversation two months earlier about an
earlier uh hostage for our uh for
terrorist swap that we did about 10
years ago for a soldier who had been
held hostage for five years named gilad
Shalit and his son Aon who is now a
hostage told his father at the time if I
ever fall into the hands of kbal oramas
I forbid you for making any deal on my
behalf I don't want you to make any deal
on my behalf so he might be sort of an
extreme voice but so if you want to look
in the middle of the spectrum you have
prime minister netan and the other
members of the war cabinet saying look
the reason we were able to get the 108
hostages out that we got out during the
temporary Seas fire that we did for
seven days uh that ended a year a a week
and a half ago is because of our
operations on the ground and if we
hadn't done the ground operation and it
hadn't been as Fierce as it was at the
outset already then Hamas wouldn't have
danced so you know there are two ways of
looking at it one is that it's a way to
compel Kamas to make a deal to let them
out and the other one is that you can't
stop you have to eradicate Kamas and
we'll bring them back at the end what do
you think the next step in all of this
is so obviously the ceasefire is over um
Rockets are starting up again there's
still the 100 plus hostages I mean what
what is
next so there are two there first of all
we have to we have to eradicate we have
to finish the job in Northern Gaza in
the center of Gaza and then we're also
working in the South now and one of the
key places that we have to take over is
uh Rafa which is the Border area between
Gaza and Egypt and you know I've been
very concerned all along that we didn't
do this first because it gives them
continued control of an international
border and we already know that there's
a lot of smuggling of weapons and I hope
not people uh going through uh the the
Border area with Egypt so we have to
take care of that and the Americans are
very opposed to Israel taking control of
Rafa but if we don't do it then we can't
win so that's the major stepping stone
in Gaza that we have to take care of and
and then there's a whole Lebanese front
that really hasn't we haven't begun to
deal with and here too we're in a clash
with the Biden administration because we
recognize that there is no solution
other than a military solution to the
problem on the border where you have
kisala uh terrorists they're Veterans of
the wars of Afghanistan Iraq and Syria
and uh they've been trained to invade
Northern Israel and they're right at the
border fence and they also have
150,000 missiles and Rockets pointing at
isra Isel that they can shoot up to
4,000 Rockets a day a day at Israel and
a lot of them have major major payloads
they can do strategic damage to the
country every inch of the country so
there's no diplomatic solution to that
and we also can't send the 60,000
Israeli civilians back to their homes in
the Border communities until we've taken
care of the threat and The Americans on
the other hand are saying no no no we we
want to avoid a war and they're trying
to push this diplomatic deal with
hasbalah that would require Israel to
surrender sovereignty
territory uh tobala in exchange for
another temporary ceasefire which will
just further imperil the country so we
have sort of two clashes over uh the
border between Gaza and Egypt on the one
hand and the border and the Border Zone
with Lebanon on the other hand that
we're going to have to try to figure out
how to how to navigate do you think that
survival is uh baked into the code with
the Jews obviously as we're talking
right now we're we're in Hanukkah it's
the it's the story of surv rival of the
Jews in the Judean Hills where Rashida T
doesn't want any Jews to live right now
but Jews have been there for over 2,000
years it's actually quite more than that
um but that the survival peace is is in
it everything you're saying it's like
here we go another challenge another
holiday commemorating another disaster
but we're still here and we will be here
after
this you're right I mean it is part one
of the enduring characteristics of the
of Jewish history really is that and we
talk about it on Passover during the
Seder where we sing a song that says in
in every generation our enemies uh stood
up to destroy us and then God saved us
from them and here we're seeing it again
and it is sort of there's a Poetic
Justice almost in the fact that we're
marking uh Kaneka now that the War Began
with a with a one- day Holocaust on Sim
Tor the last of the four high holy days
uh at the start of the Jewish New Year
and now uh we're entering the third
month in Hanukah because Kaneka and I
and I spoke about this on on my show
yesterday which is that you know Kaneka
is sort of a it's a it it commemorates a
victory over two types of anti-Semitism
one is a physical one like Kamas that
comes in uh and wants to physically
annihilate us or Iran or or kisala but
the other one are the people who are
denying us our our right to our own
identity to our Traditions to our
heritage and to our land so the the the
sort of progressive Jews of that time
the heniz Jews were saying well we
should take on the Greek ways we should
make sacrifices to the Greek gods they
set up a a c a a statue of Apollo in the
temple in in Jerusalem and they were
making sacrifices to it and all kinds of
other idolatrous uh practices that they
were adopting from the Greeks and uh the
Greeks themselves were denying Jewish
history saying that we had no right to
the land I mean it was very very similar
2,150 years ago to the kinds of things
that you're seeing on college campuses
today and at the UN where where you have
the full breath of Jewish history just
being erased from the record and being
replaced by this fake history that that
doesn't include anything Jewish in the
land of Israel so it's very similar and
it's extraordinary it's remarkable how
when it comes to the Jews at least
history always repeats itself always it
it never changes always just constantly
repeating itself and never as Force
do you think there's something that
Israel could do to to not repeat itself
in terms of the pr War which it always
it seemingly always loses I I've sort of
come to the position that Israel should
stop offering their PR people and their
and their members of parliament and
everything to any of these news
organizations no country should have to
defend their right to do whatever they
have to do to survive as you said it's
an existential battle and they're being
put on with largely Progressive Maniacs
who would who would love for the state
to fail so so why do it do you think
that there is a different way to look at
PR going forward I mean I suppose this
will change everything one way or
another look I you know my personal
theory of PR and of diplomacy and of
really everything in in in life is to be
good to your friends and bad to your
enemies because then people will want to
be your friends and they won't want to
be your enemies and so I think the idea
of trying to make nice give Scoops to uh
press organs like the New York Times uh
or NBC news or what have you is is just
self-defeating you shouldn't do that you
should be giving the Scoops to uh to the
news organizations that actually you
know support you and want you to win and
then and then dry the rest of them out
there's no reason why they should be
benefiting from any sort of uh ancient
Prestige that they earned a hundred
years ago and have since completely
squandered so I I agree with you I think
we do have to change the things that
we've been doing I've been I've been
arguing this for two decades actually
and it's sort of a sopian task because
it's always that shiny bright object
right there oh we're gonna get a we're
gonna get good coverage in the times oh
they're going to say something nice
about us here or there and and I think
that it's almost a battered wife
syndrome that you just say you know
let's let's maybe they'll like us
tomorrow if we if we make the soup just
right so I think you know we you're
right I I I long ago abandoned the idea
that that anybody who is not you know
willing to countenance the truth is ever
going to want to countenance the truth
because for whatever reason the cost
benefit analysis that they do
professionally personally and what have
you uh doesn't factor in uh truth and
and and right so why should you try to
argue with them on things that they
don't care about has there been much
discussion about whatever the security
failures were or is that just kind of
being punted right now in the midst of
trying to deal with the hostages and
everything
else well I think both because because I
mean I think you know we don't want to
have a commission of inquiry on any of
this until after the war I suspect
although I mean I think what's come out
already is at the head of military
intelligence a man named Major General
Aon khwa uh really probably it's it's
actually unacceptable to me personally
that he hasn't resigned already because
we we found out that Israel has just you
know that there was a profound failure
on his part and on the part of his
senior officers in in the intelligence
director where we had the actual plans
for the invasion and their training for
it were being tracked on a daily basis
by the uh by the field observers at the
border who were you know we have all the
security cameras who were you know who
are who are glued to their positions 247
watching all the movements at the border
and they were constantly warning that
Hamas was training foreign Invasion
replete with taking of hostages and Mass
Slaughter and uh and the head of the
intelligence just uh dismissed
everything as unrealistic as a fantasy
and he didn't inform uh the prim
minister of any of this or the defense
minister so I mean this was really uh
something that is definitely a firing uh
offense and and yet you know he and
other top officers have said uh we
failed it's our responsibility it's our
fault and then none of them quit so I
think in particularly in the case of the
intelligence uh head
khwa that you know I I wrote an article
some weeks ago calling for him to resign
immediately um but you know we we but
but I think we're going to have to look
into all of this and part part of the
problem is that it's not simply a
question of how does how did the
military assess threats what they
understood Kamas to be how how in their
imagination uh Kamas really was and that
they believed that Kamas was not uh had
moderated for whatever reason because
they wanted to but I think it's part of
an overall conceptual framework an
ideological framework that has guided
just as is in the case in the United
States since 911 that our our Elites uh
have preferred to to tell themselves a
story about our enemies that is
convenient for them but it doesn't
reflect the identity of our enemies so
and this has a lot of ideological Roots
it has a lot of social Roots so it's a
much more difficult thing for one
Commission of inquiry dealing with one
specific issue to deal with I think as a
as a country as a society we have to
have a Reckoning with these people in
our sort of in our ruling class and and
how they misunderstood reality and tried
to frame it in a way that made them
comfortable and that put their
advantages in the front um and and block
the path of others that that actually
leads me to my last question just
because we're short on time but do you
sense that what will happen in Israel
after this will be a massive
generational shift where the young
people that are that are the soldiers
right now in Gaza um will eventually
take leadership roles over the next few
years and we and there will be this new
almost like a sort of new Israeli
rebirth politically culturally
philosophically all those things sort of
what we're trying to do in America right
now we've got two octogenarians running
for president all everything you just
described about the Elite Class
protecting themselves not protecting the
people not understanding the way the
world really works and if people say
want to kill you maybe they do that it
might lead to something actually quite
extraordinary after all this even though
maybe it's a little hard to see at the
moment um you know it it's like the
difference between your head and your
heart and um your heart tells you one
thing it tells you that yes that's
exactly what's happening in Israel that
Israeli Society is also undergoing an
earthquake and that are our people on
the front lines uh and our people who
get it you know behind and who have
always gotten it that that there's this
ground swell of of of a a scream really
for Change and for a reckoning on the
part of our failed leaders and for the
the the entry of new leaders into into
the lifeblood of this country and and
leading it in leadership roles um the
fear that you have in your head is that
the uh entrenchment of the powers that
have controlled our country for so many
decades is so deep uh that they're going
to figure out a way to withstand the
pressures coming from the ground so I
think that we're in a very Dynamic uh
position right now I believe that we are
on the verge of a major shift in the way
things are done in Israel but a lot of
this so depends on our winning this war
um so many good things await us at the
end of this very dark tunnel that we're
in but we have to get through it and we
have to win like we don't have any
choice because if we fight to a draw if
Hamas in any way survives this if kisala
isn't pushed away physically from our
border in the north then then it it's
going to be much more difficult to get
to the place that we have to get to as a
society Carolyn I thank you for your
time happy Hanukkah to you and your
family and Le let's do this again in a
couple weeks and you can keep us posted
on what's going on over there I'll be
happy to join you anytime thank you for
having me on Dave thank you very much
thanks if you're looking for more
enlightening conversations about
international issues check out our
International playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell